Windows presents scenes from this season
of The Walking Dead let me let me put
this to all of you as clearly as I can
I'm not in charge anymore
how did you get yeah you work for me
you get is the people here call this
place Kingdom
we were helping you swap in helping them
[Music]
tell them about what happening babe I
really don't for we go I mean it's
usually something what I did to him
we got split up you found trouble I
found you that is all he knows and
impunity person who's in charge of this
place
person having named Morgan yeah he um
he's called king of Zeit you
yeah King zq and he does his own bang
[Music]
hey guys it's Charlie so new footage for
Walking Dead episode 2 the kingdom just
teasing the kingdom so we're gonna do a
breakdown to that surprisingly I was
able to make this without spoilers for
episode 1 couple big things happening in
next week's episode we're gonna meet all
the people at the Kingdom King Ezekiel
I'll talk about them in a second but
we're also going to see where the
Savior's home base is so like you see
Dwight here trying to torture Daryl
we'll see a little bit of that really
like the biggest new thing because we've
already seen a lot of the Savior's in
this first episode they're terrible
they're very organized super dangerous
you want them all to die the kingdom I
think is gonna be a lot more fun just
because you've seen like this terrible
negan character he's like the devil so
you expect the kingdom to be this
juxtaposition where he's like Jesus or
God you know some benevolent religious
figure like if you were watching lost
again think of it as like man and black
in Jacob you have you know like two
people on two different sides of this
conflict but the funny thing about
Ezekiel and you kind of see it in that
Carol clip there where she's like you
know what what are you talking about in
Morgan's kind of having a little bit of
a problem trying to find the words
explaining how eccentric Ezekiel is he
kind of does his own thing like that's
his way of explaining Ezekiel as he's
pulling Carol into what you see is a
church here so you see King Ezekiel
there's this quote by him up on the wall
hope is the North Star let it guide you
the initials here are King
Ezekiel like it's his quote so obviously
he thinks very highly of himself so the
fun of this moment is just in seeing
Carol scoff at all this like oh my god
this guy is totally crazy we need to get
out of here now this is just as bad as
the Savior's so it really does seem more
like a cult even though they are helping
out like Morgan says they've been
helping you so I've been helping them so
you would think that they're super nice
but then you have all this crazy
religious stuff going on so the thing is
is that even though the Kingdom is kind
of like on the other side of this
conflict from the Savior's like they're
not in league with the Savior's they're
not gonna ride in like the cavalry and
solve all the survivors problems even
though they have horses and armor but
really the whole point of this episode
is just in getting to meet these
characters
like oh you've met negan now it's time
to meet the other guy on the other side
of this so let me know even if you guys
haven't read the comics who do you think
is more nuts
negan who's a complete psychopath or
Ezekiel who thinks of himself as this
religious icon so the real twist is is
that both the Savior's and the kingdom
are kind of like cults like you have
this cult of negan the way some of the
Savior's worship him they worship Him
more out of fear but then you have va's
iki o who it seems like wants to be
worshipped by people as well but they
are doing a lot of comic-book stuff
it'll be fun to see how Jesus interacts
with them because people call him Jesus
so much so you have Jesus in Ezekiel now
suddenly things are getting very
religious on the walking dead but the
kingdom stuff will be like a nice exhale
like a little bit of relief after that
intense negan episode but we get to meet
Shiva we'll get to meet Ezekiel all the
other people of the kingdom so it's
gonna be a lot of fun but it doesn't
necessarily mean that all their problems
are solved so I'll be posting my episode
2 video after it airs next week be sure
to subscribe to get that if there any
other Walking Dead bonus videos that you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments I have a crazy DC video
about Superman and Batman that I'm going
to post tonight
so that'll post a little while but
congratulations to this week's Walking
Dead giveaway winner Niko's Guevara you
win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there will be a new round
that'll start when I post that episode
to video so whole bunch of comic book
stuff happening this week make sure you
go see Doctor Strange there'll be a
bunch of Marvel DC and Walking Dead
stuff happening all comic book stuff
sometimes you forget that The Walking
Dead is a comic book series so get hype
it's gonna be awesome
I like how negan called Rick King [ __ ]
and now we have King Ezekiel so we're
like kings of the apocalypse so while
you guys wait for that next video to
post you can click up top for my episode
1 video like the full video and you can
click down here to learn about what's
going on behind the scenes with Deadpool
2 and you can click down here to learn
what's going and you can click down here
to learn about the big WTF stuff that's
happening behind the scenes on dev
- so thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight